we have the story from bounding into
Comics Dungeons and Dragons to remove
half species from players handbook
claims the entire idea is inherently
racist wow
so let me put it simply the idea that
there are mixed race species in the
world of Dungeons and Dragons they deem
should not be in the game anymore
because it is racist oh yeah yeah they
are saying that race mixing is racist
you don't think that's the breeze half
the reason for the hatred for Clarence
Thomas
Clarence Thomas is married to well I'm
friends with Jenny Jenny Thomas a white
woman AOC that is a major major issue
sort of I mean aoc's uh I don't know
fiance or husband I don't know if
they're married is white and Kamala
Harris is married to a white guy or
whatever right so well what is aoc's
ethnicity she's uh she's what is she
she's Latina she's a Latina but I don't
like of what persuasion but she's she's
not white I mean the left considers
Latinos white if they vote Republican
and they consider black people white if
they vote Republican too I don't know
that's why I'm confused but so so this
this one was really funny to me when I
saw this wizard the coast revealed that
they will be removing the concept of
half species from The Dungeons and
Dragons player's handbook on the grounds
they are not comfortable including an
inherently racist Concept in the game
what what's racist about mixed race
characters I I wonder is something wrong
well the the the the racial fanaticism
that really bugs me is the decision to
capitalize black and white
oh yeah in description which is straight
out of South speaking of African yeah
straight out of South African apartheid
did you see that uh that judge who I
guess I don't know what the story was he
reprimanded the uh the woke uh the
lawyer for his pronouns in the in the
pleading he said you're adding extra
words for no reason an attempt to
persuade uh an officer of the Court by
in making political implications you
capitalize the word black but not white
oh that was a different one yeah no the
same one oh yeah yeah and then the the
it was like it was a prosecutor or
something he put pronouns in it and the
judge basically said that including your
pronouns only attempts to signal to the
court that you are of a political
persuasion to seek favor we have a case
in Minnesota public teachers union in
Minneapolis
they put in a contract that you know if
there's a layoff you get laid off
usually the most recent
employee you know the most recent hire
first in first out right you don't have
the EXP you have to be on the job longer
in order to get the benefit of not
getting laid off except if you're black
or white
so if you're a black person who
otherwise would be fired they go to the
next person who's white and fires them
yeah and on the back end rehiring it's
usually you know the most senior person
gets first unless they're the wrong
color so this there's this it's not it's
it's not like they in favor racial
discrimination they embrace it and they
reject
the Constitutional prohibitions on
racial discrimination and the civil
rights laws of the 60s they don't
believe in them it's been this way since
I was a kid they don't believe in them
Chicago has always operated as long as
I've been alive this has been a
component that friends of mine and my
family have have dealt with that if you
were white
if you are perceived as white they would
skip you in in public hiring or public
promotions and that was that was normal
well you know but that's an internal
ethnic issue in Chicago versus a public
school Union with the endorsement of the
city engaging in braces no I'm talking
about police and fire departments right
outright saying white people need not
apply oh right right with the with the
racial quotas at the time right and
California they had quota requirements
for private boards they said you you had
to have so if you have a just you know a
quota means that someone gets a job
that no one else can apply for because
of their race or whatever the quota
requirements that's a huge thing is
South Africa as well as racial quotas
it's like one of the major things
honestly but in South Africa do they
have quote the quotas apply to white
people uh yes it's like you have to hire
I believe it's like every which I hire
one white person entire three black
people and they could be black people
with any every any tribe doesn't matter
but they have to be three black or
colored people in that position so no
matter what even and this is important
for people to understand colored means
something specific in South Africa yes
colored is a proper word capital c o l o
u r e d colored it refers to mix mixed
race right yes correct who speak
Afrikaans it's like their main language
yeah that's that's funny because in the
United States it's just considered like
a slur or an insult right but in South
Africa it's like a legal term it's
illegal it's the the name they use for
themselves yes and it's capitalized
that's why I was talking about the
capitalization of race is pernicious uh
that you know like I keep on saying they
don't believe in any of the kind of
well with the liberal basis for our
country has been for the last 50 60
years that we're supposed to be treating
people according to something other than
their race or or sex or now you know
lgbtqt status or whatever it's you you
get special treatment and others get
punished
uh it is it is a um you know how how is
it you run a Civil Society on that basis
I have no idea South Africa tried it
didn't work yeah it's uh it's I don't
think it's working
right I mean it didn't work under
apartheid and it didn't work in the
efforts to undo apartheid where they're
as race conscious in theory as they were
during the apartheid it's it's it's more
race conscious than it ever has been I
think and uh it's not helping it's never
helped I just I just with this DND thing
there's no other way to see it they are
white supremacists
and they are projecting to protect
themselves this is what the left does
they create segregated spaces there was
the famous uh Library I think was
Seattle where they had
um POC non-poc Library meetings yeah so
it's like well if you're white when I
was at um just to remember it's schools
across the country they engage in
segregation these safe whenever you hear
Affinity space sub segregation
that's what they mean it's literal
segregation in uh court or you know
government endorse segregation there was
that that's what's happening apparent in
Georgia who sued because her child who
was black was taken out of the mixed
classroom and put into an all-black
class and she was like why and they're
like for his safety and she's like what
that's what they're doing so these
people are like we shouldn't allow
anyone to play a character who's
actually mixed race because
race mixing is racist they say they're
trying to alter the culture to change
people's perceptions and it seems like
what they what sort of Communism is that
I'm trying to think through Communists I
know but what I mean the com there's
communism behind it I'm just trying to
think through what is its what is what
sort of Communism is it evidencing what
do you mean that this racialism
prohibits race mixing
is
I don't even understand it from the
Marxist perspective because there isn't
one the only underlying ideology to what
they're saying is they don't want people
to mix to raise me that's just just like
a vicious racism and they're doing it
under the guise of fighting Against
Racism this is what they have always
done they say we are not racist it's
actually Larry Elder who's a white
supremacist right
and there you go now I read this uh
article I think in the root a long time
ago about a woman saying like we
shouldn't glorify black men dating uh
light-skinned black women or women who
are not like black women of a dark skin
tone because it's encouraging uh this
idea that black women aren't enough and
they they're it was like this this
argument that I found very interesting
because they're saying basically we want
to see people of the same race together
when it applies to this racial group I
mean in Harry Potter the people who were
encouraging just purebloods were the bad
guys and it seems like in a couple years
we've turned away from this well you
know and it's interesting because you
have this on the other hand this kind of
crazed commercial uh interest in
depicting interracial families
as if you know the to me it's kind of
Reverse Racism as if they're too afraid
to depict
uh uh an entire black family or an
entire white family but you know the
only reason the black person can get in
the commercial if they're married to a
white person these days I mean it's it's
I mean this is where we are yeah and and
I think it's and it doesn't make you
know and I guess the communism is it
doesn't make sense it's disruptive and
the goal is to destroy the system my
chaos is key I think I think the
Communists were racist Marx was racist
Shea was racist racist yeah and they are
racists and what they're doing is
they're encouraging policies that
enhance racial tensions and and they
actively promote segregation they're
they're white supremacists feigning a
guilty conscience yeah the left the left
is long used racial division to you know
to to advance the revolution if I put it
this way Democrats
if I were to tell you that Democrats
were imposing racist policy if you were
not American all right you've never
heard of the country and you started
reading the history of this country then
you showed up here on you know you land
at JFK and you walk out and you're like
wow America first time here and someone
came to you and said Democrats are
racist what would that person say
well they're supporting well a person
who doesn't know has never hasn't read a
book about the United States they'd say
that is correct they would say they
support yes I read this book I know
exactly what you're talking about right
they supported slavery they supported
Jim Crow uh they opposed the civil
rights movement and now they're
reimposing segregation in school
districts the country and apparently
people have left us persuasion think
race mixing is racist yeah that's they
don't really think it's racist they just
want an excuse to get rid of it the core
love story of Lord of the Rings is a
race mix it's a human and an elf it's
all you can't have that yeah we could
see and I could see in 20 years that
they're like we got to rewrite that it's
no good this is uh Hasbro Wizards the
coast is owned by Hasbro I believe
directly and then they're they're funded
by the Vanguard group where they
actually owned by Vanguard BlackRock
Capital research Global Investors the
three of those companies own about 30
percent of Hasbro then there's this guy
Alan G hassenfeld who owns six percent
of the company so it's like
multinational corporations that are
talking about how to people of different
races finding love together or coming
together right you know and they don't
want people to love each other they want
everyone to be angry at each other you
know I get the whole idea anything that
shuts us that you rise above
in a spiritual or moral way uh you know
the divisions that you know keep us you
know uh sinned or sinful it's something
to left opposed they want to raise
everything that hurts America hurts
human beings I could get the argument
make that there or make that their basis
if they were to say like oh well it's
because an orc took a human woman back
to his tribe you know like they're
they're no no they're saying that to
imply that an elf who is half human is
only half elf is racist because he's an
elf oh like they could call it a half
human that's the whole game is written
from the human perspective no no that's
not what they're saying they're saying
uh Alpha has to be able to identify as a
full Elf yes you can't treat them as an
half negative you get Elven abilities
when you have a half when you have an
elderly father that's how it works you
get half you get your night vision just
saying you have infrared vision they are
saying
if a person is half elf they are Elf
that's it but if that's not quite though
that's what they're saying right now I
understand they're trying to change it
to they are changing it so they're
saying if you well what about a quarter
elf nope nope you're still an elf you're
still enough that would actually be
illogical this is the racial tenants of
the Democrats hundreds of years ago
and we laugh at it but it's I mean the
extremism is a feature the you know it's
oh yeah you know we say well it's a
slippery slope and it's like yeah I mean
they they you know we laugh but they say
yeah this of course is this is logical
to us and you know you're going to get
with the program we're going to make you
get with the program I understand the
human-centric thing and maybe that's a
mistake because you could have like a
half orc half elf person uh they don't
have to be human so maybe they could
they should have went that they should
go in that direction where you could
have like a Dwarven elf a dwarf an elf
yeah that'd be cool did you say you only
get night vision if your dad's well
elves have night they have infrared
vision they can see in low light vision
they can see up to 60. but it's only
passed paternally Oh either either as
long as you have Elven blood you're able
you have some of the Elven ability but I
would love to see the game go like more
race mixing like a Dwarven orc you know
I have to work very much for them I
guess wouldn't it be amazing they
wouldn't be comfortable one of my great
grandmother was an elephant but my
great-grandfather was an orc and my my
other great grandmother was a human
they're just writing this these kinds of
characters out of the game or
oh my God
let's go back in time to when there was
racial segregation the the the the rules
they imposed the racist was basically
like if any part of you is non-white
then you are not white yeah and so
they're literally doing implementing
this right now like you're not a human
you're an elf it's like no but I'm half
no you're not you're an elf like you're
not human that's what they're basically
saying
if you have a human mother and an elf
father I mean let's just let's just this
is funny let's just say that their
ideology of what they're explaining
let's replace human and elf with just
like um Indian and Japanese
what they're basically saying is that
one one group looks at the individual of
two races and just asserts they can only
be one imagine there was a kid and
that's how it works in the United States
Barack Obama is black despite the fact
that he's half white right that's the
view of the left he is not white he is
black and that's that that's in in this
world that's all he's allowed to be to
me that's crazy
but that's that's how they've always
viewed it because they're racist yeah
there you go I'm holding out for the
quarter elves
and I want to see if they can see 15.
I'll tell you this I'll tell you this uh
when I was younger is it racist or
racialist
you know racists I'm always a little
hesitant about the racism because it is
racist because the racism suggests that
someone has negative characteristics
because of their race as opposed to
being obsessed with race per se and
using that and I'm being charitable
frankly I'm just Rising a point I think
I believe it's generally racist it is
but there's this but I think there's
this broader issue of racialism
that is that is part of the the Marxist
effort to destroy the country by
categorizing us whether we want to or
not and putting some people into good
boxes and other people into bad boxes
and um you know what they run into I
think in their racialism and this
probably explains this is that folks of
mixed Races they aren't quite sure what
to do so now they've got their Rule and
you're going to go into one box or the
other it's all because if you straddle
the boxes then the whole the whole it's
always been this way the whole construct
a lot it's always been this way and it's
never been you're one of the other
you're always the other with growing up
this was explicit to me because I have I
have a Korean mom I will never be white
according to the government I am not
white I can't be white I can never
identify as white even though I'm more
white than Asian I am Asian end of story
and what would you now on the Korean
side how would Koreans consider you
white
they would they say you're white even I
mean
uh my understanding Koreans are a bit
different they're very racist very very
racial supremacist so they would find
Value in the fact that I'm part Korean
and be like oh wow but lesser than them
so it's not it's not so much among the
younger generation of Koreans right but
the you know like 50 like the older you
get in terms of Korea the more racial
supremacists they are and the Korean
supremacists they that Koreans older
ones genuinely believe Koreans are the
Supreme race no joke and it it emerged
my understanding not just over whites
but other Asians as well everyone yeah
they believe they're the superior rest
of the planet and the reason they do my
understanding is that when Japan invaded
and and you know colonized parts of Asia
the Japanese claimed that they were the
Supreme Race So Korean resistance
countered this by claiming to their
children and Fighters no it's actually
us and we'll prove it then when Japan
ultimately gets repelled in the koreas
you know everything happens it happens
they retained that view that they were
supreme but I gotta tell you when I went
to Seoul one of the funniest things I've
seen was in this Museum talking about
the great Naval general or whatever and
its tremendous victories over Japan but
as you go step by step through his
career it's like a great victory was add
here and it shows like 50 Korean ships
fighting 50 Japanese ships and then it's
like and he was Victorious and then you
jump like a year and it's like in the
next great battle he won and there's
like 10 Korean ships and 50 Japanese
ships and it's like so you're saying
that for every five battles he lost he
won one and you're only showing me the
ones he won I thought that was actually
kind of funny I was like what else are
you gonna do like we lost a lot the
Japanese took over and you know so with
the d d game which one is better like to
your point if they're half elves half
orc you want to be half do you want my
characters half elf it depends on how
you want to play the game okay
Powers Yeah and Orcs are stronger you
General but the game doesn't naturally
favor one or the other so like in the
half elf house half human thing if you
said it was written from a human's
perspective yeah so it's better to be
well humans don't have any they're like
the most Bland General character they
don't really have a lot of bonuses or a
lot of negatives so it would be better
to be lumped in with the elves because
they're more powerful no because they're
they can they die they have less hit
points they're physically weak weaker
but they're quicker or they're they're
better with magic but you can if you hit
them they die quicker okay thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time